de qué se trata la medida anunciada hoy
por el presidente yo white
cuatro puntos principales el primero de
ello es que va a condonar hasta veinte
mil dólares en la deuda estudiantil a
aquellas personas que hacían parte del
programa pele su programa precisamente
que daba de dinero a las familias menos
de sao menos favorecidas en este país
para acceder a la educación esto con el
fin de que no sean las familias y los
estudiantes de más ingresos los que
puedan recibir esta ayuda de 20 mil
dólares en condonación de saludo
estudiantil el segundo punto es que para
las personas que no hacen parte del
programa papel pues si van a recibir de
todas maneras diez mil dólares en
condonación esto siempre y cuando ganen
menos de 125 mil dólares al año y 225
mil dólares al año si están en pareja si
tienen un matrimonio y hacen sus
impuestos conjuntamente es de resaltar
también un punto que mencionó el
presidente bailen es que la moratoria de
los pagos de la deuda estudiantil en
eeuu que se acababa la próxima semana y
que precisamente por eso el presidente
estaba recibiendo tanta presión por
parte de demócratas y de estudiantes se
va a extender hasta diciembre es decir
después de las elecciones legislativas
cristóbal habrá cuántas personas podrían
beneficiarse con esto y cuáles han sido
las reacciones por parte de los
republicanos
pues es que el tema estudiantil y del
lado de estudiantiles es bastante grave
y bastante importante en este país de
hecho 45 millones de estadounidenses
tienen un total de 16 billones de
dólares en deuda y pues él según lo dijo
yo lo dijo yo bailé en cerca de 20
millones de estadounidenses que tienen
deuda estudiantil terminarían con cero
de deuda y podrían entonces según
congresistas demócratas pues empezar a
pensar ya en precisamente formar
familias en hacer inversiones
inmobiliarias precisamente y en quitarse
ese peso encima que representa la deuda
estudiantil sin embargo pues hay
reacciones también por parte de los
demócratas de los republicanos que han
dicho que no es justo para las personas
que hicieron los trabajos que trabajaron
fuerte para pagar su deuda que ahora
pues venga el gobierno a financiarles y
a condonar deuda a otros estudiantes que
no han terminado de pagarla sin embargo
la respuesta del gobierno es que tampoco
es justo que empresas multinacionales
estén recibiendo beneficios tributarios
a fuente de empleados que sí están
pagando su parte justa en tema de los
impuestos lo que preocupa también a los
republicanos es que precisamente este
ayuda este desembolso del gasto público
ayude a incrementar un poco más la
inflación tampoco están de todos
contentos jóvenes que esperaban que la
condonación de la deuda hubiera sido
mucho más grande unos contentos unos
tristes sin embargo pues esto es según
el gobierno un alivio para muchos
estudiantes